from professional wrestling to hollywood
dave bautista is a man who can do it all
as one of the greatest professional
wrestlers of all time batista initially
rose to prominence with his storied
career in wwe competing in matches
against some of the sport's greatest
icons in the process he amassed an
impressive six world heavyweight
championship victories following a
phenomenal in-ring career bautista then
decided to hang up the boots and tackle
the world of acting following his
transition into tinsel town bautista
took roles in a number of low-budget
direct-to-video films such as wrong side
of town and the scorpion king 3 battle
for redemption before landing his big
break in 2014's guardians of the galaxy
starring his tracks to destroyer
bautista quickly made a name for himself
in the marvel cinematic universe with
his portrayal of the lovable yet
tragedy-stricken giant his people are
completely literal metaphors are going
to go over his head nothing goes over my
head my reflexes are too fast i would
catch it since then bautista has played
drax in a number of marvel films
including the mega blockbuster avengers
end game on playing drax bautista told
collider i can just relate to drax so
much it's not even funny simple things
like the tattoos the tragedy because you
know i had a bit of tragedy in my life
as well so it's really easy for me to
pull from that indeed bautista didn't
achieve the success he enjoys without
having endured a little adversity along
the way in fact the star had a
tumultuous upbringing characterized by
economic hardship and violence bautista
grew up amidst the crime wave that swept
washington dc in the 1980s for example
as a child he once saw a man beaten up
and almost thrown from the overpass from
his doorstep and also once witnessed his
own mother being attacked though those
incidents were traumatic in and of
themselves there is one event that truly
stands out from bautista's terrifying
childhood one afternoon as bautista his
sister and a number of kids were
blissfully playing outside his mother
noticed that something was off as it
turned out there was a dead body lying
outside their home the police had been
called after the unnamed man was shot to
death but were taking too long to show
up bautista his sister and the
neighborhood children however had become
so desensitized to death that the body
didn't even seem to phase them that was
the moment in which donna rae finally
drew the line she subsequently moved her
children to san francisco california in
hopes of a better life and while life in
california might have been better for a
number of reasons the bautista family's
political leanings made it a
particularly apt new home dave bautista
who is an unwavering democrat is not the
only member of his family who leans left
his mother was cut from the same cloth
she was born and raised in a highly
conservative greek american home and was
later shunned for her leftist ideologies
on top of that bautista's mother was
also open about her relationships with
women much to her family's chagrin
despite this donna rae worked incredibly
hard as a single mother to support the
young bautista and his sister moving
them across the nation and working a
night job to pay the bills it appears
that rey's fierce loyalty and caring
nature has spilled over into bautista
himself having once described himself as
the proud son of a lesbian the wrestler
turned actor revealed in an interview
with the tampa bay times that his father
never did anything for him this in turn
led to him developing a protective
spirit over his mother and this has
extended to his champion of lgbtq plus
rights bautista has often taken to
twitter to passionately defend the lgbtq
plus community and admonish anyone who
might have an issue with that he even
once called out boxing legend manny
pacquiao for espousing anti-gay remarks
in a scathing and profanity-laden rebuke
bautista told tmz that he won't accept
attitudes like that especially
considering his own mother was gay it
certainly appears that no matter where
his career may take him dave bautista is
a family man through and through
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]